salut ça c'est moi fred tous les
week-ends des filles viennent à la
maison car à 15 ans ma tite écolo
victoire 12 ans toujours dans la lune
noire sur mars même et enfin remis en
avant c'est le petit tyran mignon de la
famille elles sont toutes très
différentes parce que elles sont pas de
la même mère ouais voilà vous avez
compris j'ai trois ex laurence
marie-ange et elena et puis j'oubliais
emma la québécoise du reste de ma vie
alors c'est sûr qu'il va falloir qu'elle
s'accroche parce que leur faut trouver
sa place dans ce joyeux chaos alors si
pour certains le week-end séropos bas
pour nous c'est cardio et pour moi ces
jeunes on retrouve eric judor d'un
week-end family une série originale
disney plus bientôt en streaming
[Musique]